me being from Texas barbecue is not food
barbecues a way of life let's say we're
having a birthday party nobody cares
whose birthday it is everybody just
wants to know who's cooking because if
the right person ain't cooking the
barbecue I'm just gonna mail the gift I
ain't even coming
[Music]
few Foods feed off of fire like pizza
and barbecue so today I'm on a mission
to cook up the ultimate barbecue slice a
pie that Smoky sauce up and covered in
heaps of barbecue meat my Challenger
today is no stranger to throwing down in
the kitchen Dale's holiday is a
restaurant owner cookbook author and Top
Chef Alum who's always game for a little
friendly competition and of course we
have the perfect judges for this
showdown Bun B is a rap icon from
Houston Texas whose latest meat-centric
passion project is the pop-up restaurant
Trail burgers and Frank to the lamondo
is the chef owner behind one of New York
City's most respected slice shops mamas
too for the first time in peace Awards
history I have a chance to finish a
season with the perfect record do I have
what it takes that's for Frank and Bun B
to decide
Dale welcome to peace Awards I'm so
happy you're here are you excited thank
you for having me I mean it's pizza you
look super fabulous how could I not be
excited you look fabulous too I
looked you up thank you so today is all
about barbecue and you know barbecue
means a lot of different things to a lot
of different people so what do you love
about barbecue you know specifically I
love barbecue because in America here
it's a low and slow tradition but you
know like where I'm from in the
Philippines and in Asia barbecue is
generally fast and hot with a lot of
heat intense flavors barbecue is a big
culture Peach is a huge culture putting
together just makes sense I can't wait
to try your pizza so tell us what you
got going on today so I am making a
barbecue black pepper shrimp and bacon
pizza so it's a Tavern style pie right
so I'm from Chicago the misconception
about Chicago is they're deep dish we
are a thin crust Tavern style pie town
so that means square cut party style and
thin crust like a cracker so this starts
with a lower hydration dough that I've
pre-cooked a little bit to make sure
that you get this nice and crispy it's
not good already yeah so I like to start
with a mixture of whole milk and low
moisture mozzarella okay and I put it on
first because I don't want the tomato
sauce to kind of SOG this dough out and
I'm taking it all the way to the edges
so this is uh ground shrimp so we took
raw shrimp we've seasoned this with a
little bit of oyster sauce black pepper
um a touch of ketchup some vinegar
um and that's going to be the base of
our black pepper shrimp we're gonna go
in with a little bit of sliced white
onion uh chefs we love our bacon
cheaters bacon wins every time listen if
you're not cheating you're not trying so
and then we have a little bit of Our
tomato sauce that I'm just gonna dot
around yeah not too much I love it
already and this is also going to help
keep this nice and crispy okay so you
know for uh more of a low moisture Pizza
like these Tavern pies are I want this
to be at around 500 but what I love
about the oonies are this gets to like
9.50 so if you're rocking a Neapolitan
pie something with a wetter dough it's
perfect for that style of pizza yes but
it's really flexible I can't wait let's
go
get this baby in here
oh my gosh that looks amazing so like in
any traditional Tavern pie right you got
to cut it into squares yes
it's the party cut
so I think like any good oh look at that
any good Tavern Pie has to support its
weight
I love the sweetness to it you know what
makes this really barbecue is that it's
really like that sweet and tangy sauce
and then a little bit of heat and then
you know cooking it with fire you can
really taste it in a pie and then I love
this crack of thin crust that is this is
so delicious thank you I love it I I
think that this is a good pie against a
pizza master I don't know if it is good
enough to win it's good enough it's wet
enough to eat for sure because I'm
eating it and it's delicious you know
I'd like to see a little more Browning
on the on the edges otherwise I think
it's a really good pizza so Dale this is
spectacular but I have something special
for you are you ready to see what I'm
gonna make I cannot wait
[Applause]
well Dale your pizza again top level but
when I think of barbecue I think of jerk
I'm Jamaican so for today's barbecue
challenge I'm making a raspberry jerk
pork pizza
whoa
whoa that sounds like Morris Morris more
and I'm here for it you know we're gonna
cook with some fire today the jerk
seasoning it loves a plain first things
first I'm gonna open up this dough
marinara it's really simple crushed
tomatoes salt pepper so now I have my
cheese mixed here so I have a 50 50 as
well but I also added a little Fontina
for a little juiciness so now I I have
my signature item here this is the
raspberry jerk pork and typically it's
like allspice or pimento based seasoning
right but also you really can't have
jerk without using pimento wood but just
working with fire alone jerk seasoning
loves fire so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to just pop this in the oven
and then I'm gonna finish the garnish
when it comes up sounds good sounds
great all right let's pop this in I just
think there's something special and
something raw about cooking with the
onion making pizza this way you know
it's nothing like just being in the
outdoors the fire and then just watching
your food come to life okay I'm gonna
pull this baby
it looks delicious I'm so happy I get to
taste it first things first I'm gonna
put a little scallion on it and then I'm
gonna take a little raspberries just to
give it a little hint of something nice
and cool came out the oven you know then
I'm gonna put a little basil down I was
gonna go with pecorino but then I was
like you know I want a little feta and
then just to finish it off a little
sesame seed for a little crunch ready oh
yeah you started without me
this is my pizza pizza Waits for No One
let's take this step by step your dough
any of the best slice shops in New York
City it's crispy it's chewy I know puree
say on Pizza less is more this
proves them wrong you know I knew it was
going to be an uphill battle I'm fully
prepared I'm taking some L's today and
I'm happy to take it out of this because
this is
Stellar so Dale thank you so much it
means the world coming from you but now
we have to go to the judge's table so
we've got rap Legend Bun B here he's a
Texas native he takes his barbecue super
seriously and then we've got Frank from
Mama's too just one of my favorites life
shops in the city all right are you
ready I'm ready let's get it bud
so me being from Texas barbecue is not
food barbecues a way of life like when
people take on barbecue as a task like
if you decide you're going to be the guy
that works the grill you better know
what you're doing because you can
literally blow the entire evening let's
say we're having a birthday party nobody
cares whose birthday it is everybody
just wants to know who's cooking so
we're cooking a barbecue because if the
right person ain't cooking the barbecue
I'm just gonna mail the gift I ain't
even coming now but this is barbecue
pizza so I refer to you when it comes to
the pizza so for me what I'm looking for
is really really sturdy pizza because
these top is going to be heavy and you
don't want a flop you don't want a
little saturation of sauce giving you
it's a mess so I'm expecting just a
really good amalgamation the flavors
together I wonder if they can put
something in there that can help bring
like a smoky flavor to it right as soon
as how they don't have the grill any
access to that Real Pit smoke I love to
see their interpretation of barbecue and
flavor on their Pizza all right we've
been talking about food I'm ready to eat
some food where's the pizza all right
that was dope I'm ready to eat bring
them out guys all right Frank we got our
first pizza here now you're the pizza
expert this thing is fresh out of the
oven yeah Tavern style you know kind of
a really good approach to you know
getting toppings on the pizza it's got a
cracker like thin crust so it's not like
Chicago deep dish Tavern Styles that's
what the locals love out there so it's
meant to be a quick bite yes all right
well let's take a quick bite in this
thing let's do it
wow that's good well I would say this
might be my first Tavern style pizza and
I like it I like it's not a heavy crust
I like a thinner crust so it hits all
the buttons as far as Pizza I do see the
the use of barbecuing for one that bacon
I can't think of me ever having
shrimp and bacon in the same bite yeah
before yeah and um that was amazing
actually the flavors went together
really well the sauce is a sauce that
kind of merged Both Worlds yeah it was a
great experience for me I really enjoyed
it I like all the flavors for me
personally for a Tavern style pizza I
want a more a little bit more shatter a
little more crisp with other Carriage
um and I really didn't get a lot of
barbecue out of it uh that I was kind of
looking for but overall it's a very very
fun pizza to eat and I don't think
anybody to be a man of this nobody's
walking away from this pizza yeah it's
balanced yeah we're not kicking you out
of bed at night yeah it's very balanced
let's get this one out of here let's
bring in number two guys let's bring it
in all right we got pizza number two
here well you know what I'll tell you
one thing it's a departure from where we
were on the color Pizza very very
different yeah I'm excited to eat this
you can see how the flavors play off
each other and I will say with this
being a barbecue Pizza competition the
fact that they've got jerk pork on it
this pork should have that smokiness
that I was talking about but I gotta
defer to you
fruit on a pizza first time my first
time I reported my pizza I mean
pineapples are a kind of standard the
world over for fruit on a pizza right
but having berries on my pizza I never
had it before my life pal all right well
this is your first time for everything
let's do it all right
it's definitely jerk yeah
for sure so I wonder if that's kind of
like normally with a lot of Jamaican
food right they incorporate like mango a
lot of time to cut the spice you think
maybe that's where the raspberry Cuts in
so that the pork doesn't cook I think so
do you think maybe there's too much
topping for across this thing yeah way
too much toppings going on here again
very different Pizza in terms of even
the Integrity of the crust almost like a
hybrid of um Neapolitan and New York
style pizza lots to take on and very
impressive that they put it all together
on a compliment yeah definitely
impressive definitely impressive a
straight jerk pizza with Dish this would
have been rough yeah yeah we had been
doing a lot less talking yeah and a lot
more drinking water yeah really well I
never thought I'd have a barbecue based
pizza but today we actually had two the
problem is we got to pick one we'll go
back we'll sit down we'll figure it out
and we'll Crown somebody to win it today
it's gonna be tough we'll do it we got
it
foreign
thank you so much for being here today
we're super excited to have you I'm
happy to be here too awesome it was
great I'm a big food guy so you had me
at Food
Dale and I had a ball cooking these pies
for you this is an uphill battle I'm
standing next to the champ so hopefully
I showed up for me when it came to
barbecue and flavoring I really enjoyed
the jerk pork really the closest you
could get to having a smoked ingredient
on a pizza whoever put raspberries and
feta on the pizzas got some balls to do
it so I think you know kudos to you on
that the one thing I liked is that both
of these pizzas had flavored
combinations I'd never tried this one
had shrimp and bacon I'm a big shrimp
guy and obviously in Texas we're big
bacon people but I I found it crazy that
I never had a dish that combined both in
one bite you guys put a lot of thought
into the ingredients that you picked and
the con flavor combinations that you
wanted to try with these pizzas very
ambitious yeah but unfortunately there's
only one trophy only one person gets it
so yeah Frank and I have had to make a
decision today yeah all right today's
winner of the barbecue Pizza challenge
is
shrimp and bacon oh my God
there you go I can't believe it I can't
believe it oh my God congratulations you
wore the right chain today absolutely
and I almost had a clean sweep this
season he broke my record Dale you won
this fair and square congratulations
thank you so much guys thank you I'm
honored of no small feet I know that you
know she's an amazing competitor her
Pizza is amazing and Chicago man let's
do it taking it for Chicago Tavern pie
all the way
ah congratulations oh my God that's so
fun
[Music]